algeriens präsident bouteflika ist am
zweiten april 2009 10 zurückgetreten
heftige proteste vor allem der jungen
bevölkerung gegen eine neuerliche
kandidatur und der druck der armee haben
dazu geführt die demonstrationen nehmen
aber nicht da und man fragt sich besorgt
wie es mit algerien weitergehen könnte
heute in vechta kompakt algerien im
umbruch sind die proteste und
politischen turbulenzen nun auftrag zu
ähnlichen entwicklungen die 2011 zum
sturz der herrscher in tunesien libyen
und ägypten und zum bürgerkrieg in
syrien geführt haben die ursachen des
unmuts sind ähnlich große
unzufriedenheit der bevölkerung mit dem
herrschaftssystem verarmung weiter teile
perspektivenlosigkeit und die forderung
nach echter demokratie durch den rückzug
des kreisen machthabers und die
installierung eines übergangs
präsidenten für 90 tage konnte zwar
etwas druck genommen werden
die proteste halten aber an denen
tatsächliches ende des systems
bouteflika zeichnet sich nicht mal die
drei säulen dieses machtzirkel sind
erstens der familien-clan des
ex-präsidenten als politisches element
zweitens das militär das selber
unabhängigkeit 1962 eine zentrale rolle
einnimmt und drittens die
wirtschaftseliten die vor allem durch
staatliche aufträge vermögen wurde das
militär ist derzeit der entscheidende
akteur
es hat de facto die macht übernommen den
präsidenten zum rückzug gezwungen und
den übergangspräsidenten eingesetzt es
versucht durch einzelne maßnahmen wie
die verhaftung prominente geschäftsleute
oder politiker ein zeichen gegen
korruption zu setzen
die opposition ist zersplittert und
bietet keine alternative die
aufgebrachte bevölkerung fürchtet daher
dass sich die vertreter des alten
systems arrangieren und tatsächliche
wirtschaftliche und demokratische
reformen nicht angestrebt werden dabei
besteht erheblicher reformbedarf
die jugendarbeitslosigkeit beträgt
offiziell 27 prozent dürfte aber wie
deutlich höher sein über 60 prozent der
staatseinnahmen entfallen auf den öl und
gassektor die wirtschaft müsste dringend
diversifiziert werden und damit auch
arbeitsplätze schaffen
breite gesellschaftsschichten fühlen
sich als bittsteller in diesem an sich
reichen land zu den reaktionen im
ausland frankreich hielt sich zurück
beobachtet die entwicklungen aber genau
denn geschätzte vier millionen menschen
in frankreich haben algerischen
hintergrund die eu vertraut auch die
französischen beziehungen mit ihr und
wünscht sich stabilität mehr als zwölf
prozent des gasbedarfs der eu kommen aus
algerien
außerdem ist es ein wichtiges transit
und herkunftsland von bekannten dem
kritischen thema in brüssel
washington setzt ebenfalls auf ein
stabiles algerien als wichtigen
verbündeten im kampf gegen
islamistischen terrorismus
algerien ist mittlerweile chinas
wichtigster wirtschaftspartner im
maghreb peking investiert in
infrastrukturprojekte sowie wohnungsbau
russland ist bestrebt seine position als
historischer strategischer verbündeter
zu festigen
ägypten und saudi arabien gelten als
unterstützer des bisherigen systems
eine direkte einflussnahme in die in
algerischen entwicklungen ist bislang
nicht zu erkennen
allerdings wird dieses land als wichtige
basis im geopolitischen wettstreiter
großmächte und im energiebereich
eingestuft wie groß ist nun die
eskalationsgefahr sowohl die
sicherheitskräfte wie auch die
demonstranten haben sich trotz der
aufgeheizten stimmung bisher
zurückgehalten
schon 2011 gab es keine vergleichbare
protestbewegung die in ägypten oder
tunesien
drei gründe werden dafür genannt erstens
die bitteren erfahrungen des jahrelangen
bürgerkriegs in der 90er jahren zwei die
schwache opposition die keine massen
mobilisieren kann und drittens die
beobachtung der vorgänger und
ernüchternden resultate in den
arabischen umbruchstaaten doch gilt das
auch noch 2009 10
selbst nach dem rückzug bouteflikas
gehen jeden freitag hunderttausende auf
der straße fordern reformen und
protestieren gegen das alte system
es gab zwar einige gewaltsame
ausschreitungen aber keine größeren
zusammenstöße trotz aller spannungen hat
scheinbar bei allen bisher die von 100
oberhand behalten
ein kurzer ausblick die
präsidentschaftswahlen wurden bereits
mangels geeigneter kandidaten von
vierten juli auf das jahr 2020
verschoben
dadurch entsteht eine übergangsphase die
einerseits viel unsicherheit birgt
andererseits aber allen akteuren zeit
verschafft es geht dabei um konzepte und
köpfe also personen die über
entsprechenden rückhalt verfügen und die
massen beruhigen können
die armee wird weiterhin die rolle des
wächters und stabilisators einnehmen
je länger aber diese phase dauert und je
weniger ein echter reformwille erkennbar
ist desto größer wird die gefahr einer
gewaltsamen eskalation